Let's go through our program and just notice everything we end up using.
One of the first things we do is call the function write,
and its argument is based on calling the function factorial of 5,
so then we have to get up here and start determining if n is equal to 0.
So function calls are definitely critical to getting the output to this test case correct.
One of the first things we have to do is look up and see if n is equal to 0,
and we'll change from 5 to 4 to 3 to 2 to 1 to 0
depending on which environment frame we're in.
We will definitely end up doing environment lookups.
If we can't do them, we don't know what the value of n is,
so we're going to start getting this wrong.
Eventually, as time goes by, we're comparing n to 0,
we're multiplying n by the result of this function call,
and we're subtracting 1 from n.
Those are all binary operators.
The equality check, the multiplication, and the subtraction--
those are all binary operator expressions.
So we are testing at least some of our binary operators.
But for the rest of these elements of our interpreter,
we're not testing them explicitly.
Even though we end up calling write, there are no string constants.
The word here, constant, is very important, like "hello" in this program.
You could argue that we're building up a dynamic string, 120,
but that's not a string constant.
There are also no local variable declarations.
A local variable declaration is different from a function's formal parameter,
and this matters because we're trying to find bugs in our interpreter code.
Since we have different Python code to handle parameters
than we do for local variable declarations,
if we mistakenly think they're the same thing,
we'll have more confidence in our program than we should. We might miss bugs.
So we're not testing this sort of thing--var temp = 2.
That's a local variable declaration.
We don't see anything like that over here.
Finally, assignment statements.
There are no assignment statements in this program.
Now, we'll end up associating with n the value 5 or 4 or 3 or 2 or 1,
but that's handled by our function call code.
We don't see anything like this--x = 2--in this input, so we're not testing it.
So while this is a good test case and it checks many things,
it does not give us confidence that we've exercised every feature of our interpreter.
We'd need a few more test cases to do that.